est-ce que vous arriveriez la
recommencer aujourd'hui en ayant 20 ans
aujourd'hui ah oui parce que j'ai envie
ces robes courtes j'ai envie ces talons
hauts
Daniel et Marie Vidal ne sont pas des
gens exceptionnels mais ils nous sont
apparus comme des gens exemples-air car
il possèdent une joie de vivre une
curiosité une gaieté tout à fait
surprenante les ayants connus nous avons
souhaité vous les faire connaître afin
qu'ensemble nous tentions de percer le
secret de leur prodigieuse jeunesse
Daniel et Marie ont eu 20 ans à l'époque
de ces années que l'on a dit de folles
ils se sont rencontrés en novembre 1924
je suis né le 14 juin
à 5 km du Puy-Sainte-Réparade dans une
ferme
dans une chambre au-dessus de l'écurie
parce qu'elle était plus chaude où déjà
était né mon père et mon grand-père moi
je suis né le 1er janvier 1905 aux
États-Unis mes parents étaient italiens
ils ont émigré un Philadelphie mon père
était pâtissier et maman l'aidait dans
la pâtisserie j'avais une sœur un frère
nous avons eu une vie merveilleuse mes
parents nous choyaient et nous adorer
quand j'ai une vent mes parents sont
rentrés en France à Lyon
je ne parlais pas le français il a fallu
aller à l'école et naturellement il a
fallu partir tout à zéro
j'ai passé le brevet je n'avais pas tout
à fait 15 ans
ce qui fait que j'ai lâché l'école et je
me suis mis comme chauffeur de ce
monsieur par la suite
j'ai eu un accident sans gravité sur la
Canebière c'était un homme qui
traversait en lisant le journal et
l'histoire s'est arrêtée là j'avais un
frère de lait qui était cuisinier on m'a
dit que c'était un métier qui nous
sauverait jamais et que je mangerai le
meilleur morceau et on m'a décidé à
entrer dans cette corporation que je
n'ai pas aimé du tout quand j'ai quitté
la classe j'ai tâté métier de coiffeuse
j'ai fait un petit peu un an par là de
fourrure et finalement j'ai constaté que
ces deux métiers ne me plaisaient pas je
me suis lancé dans la mode un métier que
je fais trois ans d'apprentissage un
métier que j'ai beaucoup aimé toute ma
vie
en 1914 à la déclaration de la guerre ma
mère était très heureuse parce que je
n'avais pas encore l'âge de partir
malheureusement la guerre qui devait
être courte a duré plus de 4 ans et en
16 j'ai dû partir d'ailleurs à cette
époque là on y allait volontiers et
j'aurais eu honte de ne pas faire comme
les autres parce que nous avions
l'esprit formé pour la revanche je
dirais il y avait une revanche à prendre
et ce qui ne partait pas était mal vu oh
la violence une chose stupide
j'ai du moment qu'on peut s'entendre
après je ne vois pas pourquoi on
s'entend pas d'abord
je suis donc parti et en 1910 8 au mois
d'août j'ai été blessé assez gravement
j'ai eu un tiers de l'humérus gauche
emporté après avoir été réformé j'ai mes
parents m'ont pris un commerce
ça n'a pas marché j'ai mangé tout
l'argent que j'ai voulu et je n'ai
trouvé qu'une solution partir aux
États-Unis quand j'ai eu 20 ans après la
guerre je me suis amouraché d'un garçon
qui n'a pas plu à ma famille du tout
alors à ce moment là j'ai eu un oncle un
frère de mon père qui est venu des
États-Unis et il a trouvé rien de mieux
que de dire à mon père ben envoie-la-moi
aux États-Unis comme ça allait oubliera
un petit peu mon père a cédé il
m'accompagnait au bateau à Marseille et
je suis parti tout seul à un Amérique
j'ai dit au revoir à mon père et à ce
moment là on me met à table et je me
trouve en face de mon mari
qui est à ce moment là je ne connaissais
pas du tout vous étiez tous les deux à
la même table seul on était face à face
à la même table mais nous étions un bout
de table
ce qui fait que nous avons pu parler
bien entendu à notre aise et je l'ai
amusé je l'ai été triste je me suis mis
à la ferrerie ou bien entendu j'ai
réussi puisque la suite vous la
connaissez c'est on a fait le voyage
ensemble jusqu'à New York ça a pas été
le coup de foudre ça s'est installé
doucement
tu n'as pas eu le coup de foudre
on peut dire que c'était cette question
de d'être dans un pays étranger de pas
connaître la langue qui nous a beaucoup
rapprochée et l'amour est venu comme ça
[Musique]
OK
pour parler souvent anglais comme ça
tous les deux
quelques fois
ça vous rappelle quoi raconter un peu
la musique
c'est un grand moment de votre vie
Amérique vous avez aimé ce pays j'ai
beaucoup aimé pour le travail le
résultat du travail c'était payé on
gagnait de l'argent ce n'était pas comme
ici là-bas on portait toutes les
semaines de l'argent à la banque ici si
on en a on va le chercher c'est tout à
fait différent
vous avez gagné beaucoup d'argent vous
aussi marie très beaucoup beaucoup parce
que je travaille à l'atelier et le soir
j'avais des clients à moi j'ai une très
belle clientèle à la mairie
j'ai servi entre autres la femme du
loup du Wall Street et c'était une dame
américaine charmante elle me recevait
jusque dans sa chambre à coucher il faut
laisser aller du chapeau pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez quitté l'Amérique tous les
deux alors vous étiez si bien là-bas
c'est à dire que je n'ai pas eu de
chance de nous étions là-bas pour le
crash vous rendez compte j'ai tout perdu
sombre page de l'histoire des États-Unis
brutal effondrement des valeurs
boursières dues à la surproduction et
aux abus de la spéculation
la crise économique de 1929 ne devait
t'épargner personne tout le monde
descendait à Wall Street on n'a jamais
vu une chose pareille et il y a eu des
suicides on ne peut pas les compter mais
en plus de ça il y a eu un chômage
immédiate
et j'ai tout perdu bien entendu à mon
tour parce que j'ai pas pu vendre ce que
j'avais parce qu'aux États-Unis il y a
des démarcheurs qui viennent et qui vous
proposent l'achat des valeurs des
actions alors on place son argent
surtout à ce moment-là ça nous faisait
que monter et puis d'un seul coup tout
est tombé dans une journée ça a été la
ruine au total et alors je me suis
décidé à rentrer parce que j'en avais
assez c'était découragé l'argent est-ce
que c'est très important dans la vie
c'est très important parce que c'est ça
une grande affaire avec la liberté qui
n'a pas d'argent mais pas libre c'est
quand j'ai eu de l'argent aux États-Unis
que j'ai pu me permettre de répondre à
certaines à certaines personnes qui
étaient au-dessus de moi ou autre parce
que je me sentais de l'argent derrière
moi si je n'en avais pas eu je me
taisais je subissais ça vous permet
beaucoup de choses ça peut pas être une
entrave d'avoir trop d'argent un
esclavage aussi oui on peut être esclave
de son argent parce que beaucoup savent
pas où le placer
ça devient quand même une obsession mais
on a on en a jamais eu assez pour ça
dans la petite maison de l'avenue du
lapin blanc tout est d'une éclatante
propreté les mains de Marie
accoutumaient à des travaux plus
délicats entretiennent cependant avec
autant de soins les objets familiers
qu'elles en mettaient jadis à draper
froncer tuyautés une capeline ou un
turban on faisait énormément des
chapeaux piqués à la machine du Japon
Lang Gandhi empaille tressé un travail
mais très très minutieux et très joli et
je me suis régalé parce que là j'ai eu
la chance de pouvoir voir des artistes
américaines qui venaient se faire
coiffer dans ce magasin même chez sax
nous avions il y avait une pique fort
qui venait non ma chérie il y avait
bête Davis il y avait McDonald's
si elle est orientée souvent vers le
passé la vie de Daniel et Marine n'en
est pas moins largement ouverte sur le
présent
tant dans votre vie
ça ça compte jusque là je n'avais pas
vécu on peut pas dire non je t'ai pas vu
je voyais ma femme le soir très tard je
partais le matin non c'est pas une vie
on est marié on se voit pas on se voit
que de nuit même pas pour manger avec
mon métier on mangeait pas ensemble les
fêtes c'était toujours séparé alors
tandis que depuis que je suis à la
retraite on est ensemble et oui c'est
plus pareil dites-moi Marie l'amour
c'est très important
quand on s'entend bien oui
mais il faut pas il faut pas avoir des
cachotteries ni pour la nuit pour
l'autre il faut être franc
la fidélité c'est très important dans
l'amour ah oui oui parce que
à mon point de vue j'estime que si on a
un qui commence à dérailler là et bien
tout va mal parce que on arrivera pas
toujours à dire la vérité et on peut
très très bien se tromper et ça ça ne
mène pas à grand chose vous Daniel
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ah moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord là-dessus
parce que de toute manière
il y a le mensonge qui intervient et dès
qu'il y a le mensonge c'est pas possible
on se contredit on dit des c'est pas
possible nous on a l'habitude de dire la
vérité moi je lui raconte tout ce que je
fais de même quand je rencontre
quelqu'un je le lui dis et ça a toujours
été comme ça
les choses ont beaucoup évolué depuis
l'époque où vous aviez 20 ans
qu'est-ce qui vous semble le plus
différent
c'est drôle quelque fois je réfléchis
mais je sais pas il me semble que
la jeunesse en service plus comme avant
et puis dans le fond on peut pas dire ça
parce que je vois que lorsque je me
trouve en société avec des jeunes parce
que j'aime beaucoup la société je ne
plus que la société des personnages je
danse comme eux je fais la folle comme
eux et je vois pas grand différence je
m'amuse avec eux comme si j'avais
l'orage alors la vie me semble pas
changer du tout parce que vous aimeriez
la recommencer cette vie comme je l'ai
faite oui malgré les embûches de gros
travail parce que j'ai travaillé très
très dur en Amérique est-ce que vous
arriveriez la recommencer aujourd'hui en
ayant 20 ans aujourd'hui ah oui parce
que j'ai envie ces robes courtes j'ai
envie ces talents haut parce que moi je
les ai porté très haut parce que j'étais
jeune et maintenant quelques fois je
m'achète des chaussures avec des talons
je les donne à droite à gauche parce que
je ne peux plus le porter alors je
reviens mais vivre cette époque
avant vraiment les jeunes filles étaient
trop tenues maintenant c'est peut-être
un peu exagéré mais avant il y avait
l'exagération d'un côté quand vous
pensez que les jeunes filles la maman le
papa fallait les avec eux et puis on
faisait pas sortir vous allez rentrer à
7h si vous allez au cinéma il fallait
pas rentrer plus tard que 8h alors ça
quand même bien changé parce que je vois
que maintenant les jeunes ne rentrent
comme ils veulent ils sortent ah oui
c'est mieux quand même vous savez on a
qu'une vie et de jeunes jusqu'à
personnes âgées il vaut mieux la vivre
comme il faut
[Applaudissements]
savourer chaque instant de bonheur qui
passe en dépit des moments difficiles
savoir goûter les moments heureux tel a
toujours été le credo de Marie
lorsqu'elle fait aujourd'hui le bilan de
sa vie elle ne peut sept pendant
s'empêcher d'exprimer un regret celui de
n'avoir pas eu d'enfant
mais
quelquefois je pense j'aurais voulu
avoir un bébé parce que ma belle-mère
avait des beaux yeux bleus de porcelaine
et je disais toujours si j'avais eu un
bébé peut-être il aurait eu les yeux
bleus et comme j'adore les yeux bleus et
c'est ce que je regarde quand il y a
Monsieur je me les ferai tellement
j'adorais les yeux bleus moi et c'est
pour ça que j'aurais voulu avoir un bébé
et vous Daniel vous n'auriez pas
souhaité avoir un enfant comme tout le
monde ça m'aurait pas déplu évidemment
j'aurais aimé avoir un garçon et quand
on réfléchit à tout ce qui se passe
avant d'arriver à ma retraite à moi par
exemple je n'aurais pas voulu que mon
fils vive de guerre
soi-même engagé dans la guerre qu'il
soit qu'il est des difficultés pour
travailler qu'il soit pris du matin
jusqu'au soir à faire quelque chose qui
ne lui plaît pas juste pour gagner sa
vie non moi je suis contre si j'étais
sûr qu'il fasse quelque chose qui lui
plaît mais à qui ça arrive
quand je vois les animaux sauvages qu'on
dit sauvage je les vois souvent à la
télévision par exemple et bien
ils ne sont pas plus sauvages que nous
même moins
vous voyez chez les éléphants qui qui
promènent les personnes âgées si on peut
dire entre deux qui sont plus solides
qui surveillent le petit
nous maintenant on les met à l'hôpital
et puis ça y est on s'en débarrasse
c'est plus pareil la famille n'est plus
comme elle était autrefois et d'abord il
y a trop de moyens de
transport il y a des facilités enfin
quand vous pensez que des jeunes gens de
15 ans ont déjà fait le tour du monde
alors que à mon époque des gens de Saint
Canada qui sont à 13 km d'Aix n'avait
jamais vu Aix je crois que le progrès a
dépassé l'homme n'a pas pu suivre je
crois qu'il est en retard et par
conséquent il faut assez difficile avec
toute la politique qui se met au milieu
la famille qui n'est plus la famille il
y a quelque chose qui doit changer c'est
pas possible que ça continue vous pensez
à la mort
oui mais
je pense pas trop souvent
c'est une fin qui doit se produire pour
moi elle est naturelle
comment ne pas y penser puisque on
assiste à des morts presque au
quotidiennes autrefois je ne regarde pas
le journal
à l'article où il est morts sont placés
dans par colonne aujourd'hui je les
regarde et
ça ne m'inquiète pas
puisqu'on doit tout y aller ce qui
m'embêtera le plus c'est de laisser
quelque chose en désordre par exemple
quelque chose qui soit pas qu'il soit
pas bien comme plus se dire aussi s'il
avait fait ça il y a que ça qui me
ferait de la peine
[Musique]